oh [ __ ]
it's a ho-hum Sunday
but it doesn't matter if it's Sunday
Tuesday Thursday morons church savages
we got to be ready tip-top [ __ ] Magoo
just in case the Koreans show up you
always got to be ready get your head
together you're gonna be ready to stab a
[ __ ] in the neck and that's what
a periscope is life comes in
tip-top Magoo uncle Joey here swinging
dick and giving our baptisms on a
[ __ ] Sunday I live close to the
airport so I got to deal with Southwest
going over and under but who gives a
[ __ ] your thing that matters is that we
showed up today 8:45 a.m. I went to
jujitsu I got up at 6:00 I did a [ __ ]
bong hit just to balance me out a
protein shake I went to jujitsu I came
back I did a little writing I sent out
some bills now I'm ready for a kids
party at 3 o'clock and then tonight 7:30
the no vote day to downtown LA I'm doing
a show of my main man wheeler
[ __ ] Walker you understand me
but as usual which the Lord today we got
to get together and let the [ __ ]
pigeons loose
we got the horse with no name we got
perennial old G and we got extra [ __ ]
13s 18 that'll make your [ __ ]
eyeballs look like ovaries last night
you understand me anyway we're here
we're queer
the fights with tremendous last night I
want to give my [ __ ] shout out to my
man mr. Alvarez I didn't think he could
do it but he [ __ ] did it
that Jason Strahan dude is a [ __ ]
what's his name Jason coupe whatever
he's a [ __ ] savage with heart over in
that [ __ ] of that Macumba whatever his
name isn't guile let me tell you
something I don't even want to blow out
the candles at my birthday party next
thing you know the cake is all over the
[ __ ] place you follow me that ungai yo
my gumbo whatever his [ __ ] name is
easy that's a bad [ __ ] you
understand me stay open you better start
eating those hot beef sandwiches the
sausage in the middle because you better
buck up do push-ups you better go to
Mexico that's a tough [ __ ] but
listen the immigrant mentality is always
there you follow me you keep showing up
and you don't give a [ __ ] just cuz you
got beat up one day you show up the next
day with a roast beef sandwich that's
the story of my [ __ ] life you follow
me but enough is enough there's no
stories today it's the Lord's Day
nice this is what family does some
families eat together our family to
church we get stoned together you follow
me a family get stoned together stays
together believe what I'm telling you
that [ __ ]
all these [ __ ] Mafia families that
went down too much coffee too much
[ __ ] everybody's Johnny Goomba we we
get together we smoke a ball he's
[ __ ] happy the attitude you got
explosions going off in your head who's
battling you we did the perennial let's
switch over to the horse with no name
cuz you know what I'm saying this
[ __ ] Sunday what are you doing here
well I can't get that high I'm going to
my parents fit that who gives a [ __ ]
that's advice scene and list arena for
you [ __ ] put that [ __ ] in your [ __ ]
batch and nobody knows nothing when mom
serves those [ __ ] those [ __ ] hot
and fresh dope pop-tarts with the butter
forget about it you'll kill all of them
even the [ __ ] basket oh [ __ ] I love
spending this tender moment when you
[ __ ] savages cuz this is what it's
all about
it's not about having 20 [ __ ] dudes
and a posse and everybody that listen
uncle Joey runs solo like The Outlaw
Josey Wales you're following me when I
came out of my mom's snatch and that cut
the umbilical cord that was it that my
father died then my mother points the
ticket so I had sling dick solo on a
[ __ ] solo tip you follow me
but I kept showing up cuz you gotta keep
showing up like a [ __ ] horse with no
name had any questions here it's the
beginning of the month you got one
[ __ ] 21 shoplifting days before
Christmas you better get on it
[ __ ] not only that six days later
is New Year's and it's 2018 and what the
[ __ ] have you done I've already heard
imagine by John Lennon I know the years
kaput I'm trying to finish the euro for
the [ __ ] bankers we think I'm doing
out here with you [ __ ] wasting
time
anyway that's it and that's that I just
wanted to touch base for you the podcast
will be up for your tip top Magoo 8:00
a.m. tomorrow morning
we never miss a beat but we ain't done
[ __ ] XJ 13 I see where all the fuss is
about you follow me like I said a little
kids party then I'm gonna get together
at 6:30 I'm gonna take a lift you know
lift press in church you get a 500
dollar brand new signing bonus I'm gonna
take a lift down the [ __ ] now de novo
do a little show get back in and come
home to Monday is a big [ __ ] day
tonight you got a bed nice and early
you're right there and you go for the
week and you come on throwing [ __ ]
heat the next two weeks cuz that's it
and two weeks from now you can't get
through to nobody visibly thinking about
jingle bells and I'm going I'm going to
Kentucky for the who gives a [ __ ] with
holiday we gotta work on something is
anyway you know me I'm always that
perennial or sunset herbal with my my
[ __ ] best people in the world
I either buy we some nice white people I
either by we from German to our Russians
I get down and dirty I haven't met no
Nazi drug dealers yet but you know me I
bought coke from [ __ ] plan one time
holla bills on Ben Franklin is Ben
Franklin no matter what color you are
anyway that's it that's that I just want
to touch base with you tell you
[ __ ] are bad [ __ ]
don't give up don't let the world get
you down when it does get you down get
up and write what you want out of your
life and don't [ __ ] stop you know I'm
saying there ain't no vacations only
with people with credit card debt take
vacations you get up every [ __ ] day
you look in the mirror and you tell that
mirror I'm a bad [ __ ]
and one way or another I'm gonna make it
[ __ ] happen today guess what if you
keep writing it down after a while the
power of time you'll [ __ ] believe it
next you know you'll be slaying their
current Kevin Spacey get him saying it's
over oh yeah they didn't get my my tail
are being gods I'd okay we'll get the
wrong color corner that's why you part
of the church [ __ ] I'm with you
you're with me and they wanna be with us
but they can't you know why because
we're too real we show up with no
[ __ ] stories no [ __ ] in them gonna
believe what happened oh my God my
aunt's a who gives a [ __ ] okay we came
to get down we came to get down jump
around jump around jump jump jump jump
and get down
anyway it's yong-chol Joey telling you
so I'd be the best week of your life all
right whatever happened last week bury
it under the carpet just remember you
how to check on your skeletons from time
to time
or not they check on you you follow me
beside that is gonna be a new week you
get up tomorrow you do 22 push-ups and
you tell the world it suck your dick
you know why the junk with Joey sent you
I love your [ __ ] have a great
dinner with your families tonight give
them all a hug you don't know when the
Koreans are gonna send a missile and
that's it and that's that but always
remember that didn't get mom I tell her
being a higher